mittwoch war halloween lassen wir uns
also mal aus gegebenem anlass über
donald trump sprechen weil es vor den
sogenannten midterm wahl nächste woche
in den usa nicht so gut aussieht für
seine republikaner macht das was er am
besten kann richtig stimmung gegen
migranten ein flüchtlingszug aus dem
mittelamerika wird zur national
bedrohung aufgeblasen hier beim üblichen
halloween empfangen am weißen haus
schickt der präsident in kleinen marios
honduras knallhart nach hause der kommt
dann zurück ich bin noch hier geboren ja
ja toll verpiss dich ja unfassbar wie
trump diesen flüchtlingszug für
wahlkampf ausschlachtet 15.000 soldaten
villa an die grenze schicken der ire
droht sogar mit schusswaffengebrauch was
für eine panikmache und das nur weil die
republikaner vor den mid term elections
schwächeln ja es ist ja fakt
andere themen ziehen halt nicht so aber
es geht immer und lügen natürlich warum
manche leute die bereits abgefangen
wurden stammen gar nicht aus zentral
amerika sondern aus dem mittleren osten
haben sie dafür beweise fragt ein
reporter nach es gibt keine beweise für
egal was aber es könnte ja so sein
könnte doch sein
hier kann doch sein immer wenn ich als
syrer in die usa wollte würde ich auch
die abkürzung über honduras und mexiko
nehmen ist doch völlig logisch der
pathologische lügner hier behauptet
stumpf der flüchtlingszug besteht quasi
nur aus gangmitgliedern terroristen und
leuten mit ansteckenden krankheiten ich
versuch's doch ich versuche wissen sie
wie schwer das ist gar nicht zu lügen ja
donald trump der mit terminator verliert
im wahlkampf die letzten hemmungen jetzt
will er sogar die verfassung ändern
damit in den usa geborene kinder von
einwanderern nicht mehr automatisch
amerikaner werden es steht eigentlich so
einer verfassung warte mal fast alle
amerikaner stammen von einwanderern ab
das heißt ja das land gehört ab sofort
wieder den indianern hier erste
reaktionen der komantschen
[Musik]
ja endlich mal eine gute nachricht
ansonsten gibt schrammt wirklich nur
noch den spalter von morgens bis abends
sind es ihm völlig wurscht was seine
aggressive rhetorik bei den leuten
anrichten ist ihm egal
ja und das hat ja konkrete folgen wie
wir die letzten wochen sehen mussten der
weitet seine partei alles um potenzielle
demokraten wähler von der urne fern zu
halten mit allen tricks in georgia zum
beispiel durften sich 53.000 menschen
nicht für die wahl registrieren weil
winzigste details in ihren papieren
nicht übereinstimmten
da fehlten dann was weiß ich leerzeichen
oder sowas und zufällig waren diese
leute größtenteils schwarze sachen gibt
ist aber nur der anfang
bald darf man den usa nicht mehr weh
wenn man zb zu gut basketball spielt
wenn man dasselbe geschlecht hat wie
hillary clinton
und natürlich wenn man keinen einzigen
wolkenkratzer besichtigt aber die dann
übrig bleiben die dürfen wirklich alle
wählen versprochen und ich freue mich
sehr dass wir heute eine echte
amerikanerin im team haben hazel bruder
geboren in san diego kalifornien hätte
wenn trump sich durchsetzt bis zur noch
schweizerinnen und deutsche wie kommst
du klar mit diesem drohenden abstieg
naja wenn mir der amerikanische pass
weggenommen wird ist das ein bisschen so
als würde mein vater mich nicht mehr zu
den vernissage ihn von seinem töpferkurs
einladen
natürlich ist es irgendwie traurig aber
hauptsächlich bin ich froh dass ich
nichts mehr mit dieser freak show zu tun
haben muss
dabei ist es ja genau dieses freakige
was manche leute an trump so geil finden
jobs befürworter lieben ja seine
authentizität so teuer wie
authentischste ist er verstellt sich
nicht er ist einfach er selber seit wann
ist es denn etwas gutes man selber zu
sein also erst einmal ist doch sowieso
nie etwas gutes du selber zu sein wenn
du selber eine wildgewordene gift kröte
bist und zweitens was ist das denn für
eine grauen auf der eigenschaft man
selber zu sein sei du selber das sagen
die leute auch ständig zu mir selber
helfen sei einfach du selber dann weißt
du schon was zu tun ist
nein du verstehst nicht ich versuche ja
gerade seit 20 jahren krampfhaft zu
unterdrücken weil ich selber wirklich
bin
damit ich sozial verträglicher wirke sei
einfach du selbst wenn ich selbst bin
bist du der erste der stirbt
aber jetzt stehen ja erst mal die
midterms an in den usa können die
amerikaner kurz zwischenbilanz ziehen
und sich fragen lassen wir das noch oder
wird es vielleicht noch ein bisschen
geiler
das ist wie wenn netflix fragt schauen
sie noch oder reichen 30 stunden nach
kos oder wenn der kellner fragt essen
sie das noch oder haben sie schon
durchfall oder wenn der partner fragt
liebst du mich noch und man schaut sich
den partner an wie er da sitzt und atmet
und denkt sich kommen wir heiraten
aber
dass das muss einfach nicht sein die mit
chips sind vor allem dazu da die
stimmung im land abzubilden
republikanern und demokraten geht es gar
nicht mehr darum zu gewinnen sie wollen
einfach nur dass die anderen verlieren
aber sowas ist symptomatisch für
krisenzeiten heute werden die umstände
einfach so lange immer beschissener
gemacht bis man anfängt sich über
selbstverständlichkeiten zu freuen
es ist ja mittlerweile schon ein
statement gegen antisemitismus wenn man
an einer synagoge vorbei läuft ohne sie
anzuzünden oder ein statement für den
feminismus wenn man mit einer frau
spricht und sich dabei nicht die hose
ausziehen was eigentlich völlig normal
sein sollte ist mittlerweile eine
erleichterung das kann so nicht
weitergehen
deswegen sage ich make no meletti normal
erkennen
[Applaus]
[Musik]